non
madame monsieur bonsoir josé bové a été
libéré dans la matinée le leader
aveyronnais de la confédération paysanne
a accepté le paiement de sa caution
mais promettre de nouvelles actions des
champignons radioactifs venant de
bulgarie et de roumanie ont été renvoyés
dans leur pays d'origine ils ont été
contaminées par la catastrophe de
tchernobyl qui a eu lieu en 1986
l'indonésie joue double jeu au timor
oriental a libéré le leader
indépendantiste mais son arme et
soutient toujours les milices
responsables de la terreur
enfin au lendemain de la rentrée
scolaire plusieurs milliers de
collégiens de lycéens ne sont affectés
dans aucun établissement scolaire par
manque de place ou d'orientation et
d'abord donc la libération de celui qui
est apparu comme le chevalier des petits
agriculteurs français